Might a fire enabled ecosystem of EHRs make all of this much easier for patients?
At a recent HL7 fire applications roundtable meeting at Duke University,
several vendors presented firebase solutions
for patients to aggregate data from all their providers.
Medley I was one of the new companies that presented at Duke.
To use their app, patients must first identify their providers.
To facilitate this, the app links to
a directory containing 4.2 million provider profiles.
To make searching easier,
patients are defaulted to their current location,
but they can search anywhere.
Having selected a provider,
patients can choose what data and date range they want to load into their app.
They then log on using their credentials for the chosen provider's patient portal.
One arm of the Medley O app seeks to create a meaningful medication list using
fire medication order resources from only the providers who wrote the prescription.
However, as you can see here,
every new refill for a prescription creates
a new fire medication order resource that makes us a long list.
A company's solution is to reconcile the orders using the RX norm CUI
number: a six digit numeric code that very specifically represents medications.
We will look at RX norm later.
They then group the orders based on this six digit number so the list,
as you see here,
contains each medication only once.
Patients can see each prescription,
the dates, and the prescribing physicians.